[Music]
14 years ago I released movie film which
brought great shame to
[Music]
Kazakhstan but now I was instruct to
return to Yankee land to carry out
secret mission I go to
[Applause]
America B what did you say no it's not
me B come back people make recognize my
face I would need disguises this man a
sex criminal no no sex
criminal I will take this to be a fat
like American man yeah this is a good
one where is
his what is problem
officer got somebody that's strapped at
the top of your car need in that
passenger seat bus only men and bears
are allowed inside
car I hear to give my daughter as a gift
to someone close to the throne and a
dress with real sexy
peels a this is a bag that just goes
over the dress they're nice I really
like this let us present Sandra Jessica
Parker
Drummond I want this one with the baby
on
it I have a baby inside me can you take
it out no we cannot that's not what we
do here I feel bad because I was the one
who put the baby in her did you ever put
one in your daughter no I did not where
is everybody they're wanting everybody
to quarantine so they don't spread this
virus could I stay your
home I hope quarantine Never
End what is more dangerous this virus or
the Democrat Democrat
Democrats killing some of the virus no
you can't see the virus no it's still
there if you think you see a virus like
that this Mak the virus sleepy and then
when it's
sleeping the Daddy has a lot to learn my
daddy is the smartest person in the
whole flood
[Music]
World while the risk of Corona virus
remains low as the president said
yesterday we're ready for
anything Michael penis I brought the for
you Bor subsequent movie film you fist
me now I fist you you what do you prefer
you fist me I fist same time fist each
other there you
go
d